what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to the
fit and fresh
podcast before i start please okay if
you could do one thing from this video
subscribe i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers i know
90 of you that watch don't even
subscribe so if you like my content you
want to support me
hit that subscribe button also let me
know in the comments
wait not this one
oh my gosh okay let me know in the
comments
if you guys like fit and fresh or you
prefer kevin samuels
oh fresh and fit i always say it wrong
when it comes to dating
what is your current view of the of the
dating market
and do you hate it or do you love it
define dating market like what's out
there what's available yeah like what
you've seen in indiana maybe on vacation
like
is it worth having a boyfriend is it
worth like going through
you know dating okay something i've
noticed probably maybe because i'm in
miami but boys are just like
thirsty i don't know they just seem like
desperate these days like coming at you
i don't know if it's like coveted time
they just haven't gotten any but
i just feel like boys are super thirsty
lately and just trying to
i don't know it's like can you give us
an example of the thirstiest thing a
guy's done
oh the thirstiest thing a guy has done i
don't know if i can think of that off
the top of my
head but um like in miami or
anywhere anywhere yeah anywhere a guy
just asked me for my number
yesterday and i said no like i have a
boyfriend
he was like can i still have it yeah no
yeah actually yeah so much worse
yeah guys do not care if you have a
boyfriend like at all
okay so hold on let's just hold that
thought so okay so you can't think of
one right now
okay i would say so your biggest thing
is that they're just thirsty
yeah just like and it's okay if you are
what i noticed was guys sending like
overly sexual messages
very early like when i barely knew them
that was like
what when i think of thirsty that's
that's what i think of don't i don't
want to know that
i don't i don't want to know that you're
i don't want it to be so apparent
because that just like is a turn off
like straight from the get-go
be a little bit more smooth about yeah
yeah i feel like people aren't smooth
anymore or maybe girls are just giving
it out left and right that they think
they can just be like hey
you try yeah i don't know maybe it's
just miami
oh my god right now i've been here for a
week translation guys you need to have
an abundance mindset
yeah and also guys on the show as well
yeah you got to do it the smart way
yeah without saying it directly yeah
yeah absolutely yeah no
direct please be smooth okay cool so uh
all right wait and
last question so do you want a boyfriend
just okay my
initial interpretation girl on the left
seems like she's got a solid head on her
shoulder this is just
face value i don't know these girls at
all
um i haven't read this girl yet these
two girls seem kind of like
out there she i'm gonna let you guys
know what i think of these two
do you wanna be single like what's up i
currently have a boyfriend okay so
i don't know if my point of view might
be a little different because of that
but
yeah okay i'm single love being single
ready to get after it but
also there is like i said like i've been
in florida multiple times there's some
nice boys like them you know but like in
miami
too much like a lot of guys are just
waiting i don't know they're nice when
they're sober and then they get like
hammered and it's like whoa you need to
relax
like spaghetti they get a little i've
seen so many guys
embarrass like kind of ruin chances with
girls by getting too drunk and sloppy
like if i had to give advice to the guys
on this channel learn how to flirt with
girls without drinking before you drink
and flirt with girls because
men that get sloppy when they get drunk
it's just
it doesn't look good it's not a good
look and you don't look like you're in
control
like you were cool but now you're just
you're a lot
okay yeah you're more smooth even when
you're hammered okay so two hands
what are we talking here too handsy just
like
weird i don't even know how to explain
it just like i guess the words that come
out of their mouth what they say
too it's just like too strong you're too
strong yes that's the word
or they think they're being smooth and
it's really just
not smooth at all but you can tell that
they're like yeah that was good
especially when they're drunk and then
you're just cringing like how do i get
them out of my room right now
the fact that we're even in there to be
honest yeah i agree
okay all right cool i'm single i like to
be single
i'm it's because i'm like pretend you're
not sitting for a second and talking to
the mic though
hold on let me care so
um i'm single i like to be single um
i was dating someone a few months ago
and we're kind of like still talking
here and there but um still having sex
okay well not having sex necessarily
talking to see if it's worth giving it a
shot again because
i i know what i want so you're not
banging him anymore no
i know they're still talking to you yes
hello stupid
yeah so like i was saying
um yes my general opinion and
again it's my opinion is that um things
aren't what they used to be
i mean i know that at every point in
time in history there's always been like
dogs out there and everything
yeah and i know there's females that are
just as bad don't get me wrong okay
but i feel like i've seen enough
to the point where i know what i want
and i'm not going to settle for this
okay so unless i find it then what's the
point of wasting my time in that other
person's time
everyone has their own opinions they see
relationships different type of way
there's all kinds of different types of
relationships but i know the type of
relationship i want to have
that doesn't make anybody else wrong i
just don't want to waste my time so
you're very picky
so you want to be single write the cc
because i'd rather invest my time in my
child and my work
and get myself settled and get to where
i want to be inside yeah i do it
all right so i'd rather get to where i
want to be in life and get my [ __ ]
together than have to worry about
someone else and their [ __ ]
right and then all the drama that comes
with oh i do think once women have a
child that the relationship comes second
because obviously like providing for
your child becomes more important than
dating you know can i justin can i not
just especially miami
like a lot of people lie i can't stand
liars i can't send liars i'd rather you
come up to me yeah that's right
you're telling me the truth to my face
and i'm not gonna like it then you lie
to me because when you lie to me i find
that anyway
because god has a sense of humor and
then i'm just doubly pissed because now
i'm pissed because
whatever and then on top of that you
lied about it did you break up with the
guard did he break up with you
well it was like a mutual thing i was
like hey this guy yeah that's what i was
thinking too
and i feel like and he agreed that he
could be a better person
so we decided to play ways until he
worked on himself
and and he got to the point of the type
of person that he feels that i deserve
and i feel he deserves
okay so in other words and tell me if i
translate this
[ __ ] yeah yeah exactly in other words
in other words
he was not on your level probably from a
financial standpoint not even financial
i really care about that i really don't
care about that it's just mentally
speaking and emotionally speaking and
i'm very big on honesty and
like what i interpreted that as he
cheated
and then when she found out that he
cheated they decided okay
we should split that was that was my
interpretation being loyal and [ __ ] like
that even
even with friends i'm very big on being
loyal and did he earn more money than
you
no okay okay we'll move on all right
so go ahead okay so speaking from well
first of all i am in a relationship
but and i don't think that this is being
in a biased standpoint like we are
saying about the money
for instance we're walking on the way
here and
this guy stops us walking his dogs and
he's like
i just moved here um i don't have my
phone
can you put your can you put my address
into your phone
he had a dog too was
this is could be me over analyzing it
but like
first of all like hi can you put my
address in your phone first of all
yeah you just moved there but wait it
gets even worse
he he goes oh can you put my address in
your phone first of all who
are you going off in the middle of the
street putting asking
strangers to put your address in their
phone to tell you how to get there
and let me tell you when we were trying
to help let me know in the comments do
you guys think that would work
maneuver his way he was not paying
attention and second of all he goes
oh you guys are so beautiful um i'm
friends with this one person
on um this um the dolphins team like all
this stuff i'm like
oh my god nice to meet you i know
someone like when i was younger
i actually have a really funny story
guys that flex like their money and
their cars and whatever
it's such a turn off for me because
again growing up
with actual money i know rich people
don't flex like that
and when i was younger i there was a guy
who i went on a couple dates with and he
invited me to go to this like party with
him
and he told me it was for this guy
jabari parker and i literally was like i
don't know who that is
and apparently i find out later that's
like a really big like basketball
player i guess but i don't watch sports
like that or care
and i literally was like i was like i
was like
nah i don't know who that is but and i
got like school tomorrow or something
but it's just funny because i feel like
these type of girls would like jump
on that opportunity that's like that i
know someone from the dolphins team like
congratulations and i think also it's
not only that
but i think a man flexing his money is
just as disgusting
yeah that's what i'm saying you're just
as low as someone who and that guy
literally was always like i have so much
money like
literally just talked about his car
money everything
has nothing going for themselves and i'm
not saying from a money standpoint
but i think that it's really disgusting
any individual
man woman or anything like just
flexing their money i like humble i yeah
i agree
and but i would also wonder if she would
have that same
mentality when girls say i can make my
own money i don't need a man
someone who's humble is the most
attractive thing
confident but humble and i think that
there's a fine line between
you know flexing and like it's like you
know
being good with what you have instead of
just doing that
so homeboy is trying to flex for his
dogs not just his dogs but his friends
on the dolphins
whatever it's called with dog game with
hero featuring hero
to do it correctly because [ __ ] don't
don't do it secondly he's flexing with
knowing a dolphin player like bro at
that point i was like bro this nigga's
capping hard
one yeah and then two he's trying
way too hard just to just like show
social you know proof for that like
that's just too much and then that's
where you live you know i i think
that he needed us to get home and then
it wasn't about the address anymore he's
like a double duty but doesn't have a
phone with the gps
on the corner and if you met someone and
you've only none them for
five to 15 seconds i don't think you
should include your friend is on the
dolphins
you know what i mean is that relevant do
i care i thought you were trying to get
home buddy
yeah were you trying to get home or are
you trying to tell me i like her
i think i like it i mean exactly exactly
because i agree with that
good um no i was just listening very
closely what they were saying
and the thing is for the guys out there
that are listening we've talked about
this on our podcast before but i love it
that women are kind of echoing what
we've told you guys
remember guys discovery always trumps
disclosure so if you have a lamborghini
and the girl finds out you have a
lamborghini naturally
versus you telling girl or go to
lamborghini it's gonna be far more
attractive
versus versus you overtly telling her
what you do because
when you try hard it's a very big
indicator that you're lower value
because you're trying to impress a girl
if you're not trying to impress and
you're just living your life and she
finds out on her own
it's gonna be far more attractive for
her so yeah that's good advice
that's really good advice yeah guys i
mean it's it's very like um and i'm glad
all of the guys that put their money on
their facebook i'm telling you
from someone that like i know a lot of
rich people that
makes you look low class and it makes
you look broke you brought that up
because we say that on a podcast all the
time yeah
and they think like we're just capping
like no no go ahead and flex and all
this other stuff i'm not saying
if you're gonna flex you have to do it
in a way that isn't like ostentatious
where you're like trying too hard you
know what i'm saying because women are
repulsed by that so
very interesting point and the other
thing too that i want to touch on that
she mentioned was
this is why we tell you guys to be
direct when you talk to women and what i
mean by is like
an indirect opener like can you help me
get home and put my address in your
phone
pathetic that's that like you're
basically you're squirting
responsibility like we tell you guys all
the time just go up to the girl okay
look at her she's looking at him with
like googly eyes
like look look at her hey listen i found
you attractive i want to take you out
what's your name and if she says no cool
walk and talk to another girl but when
you do this this is this
this way [ __ ] and you're being
indirect
well you're sending different signals
and more importantly it conveys to the
woman that you're not confident
you know what i'm saying so i'm glad
that you mentioned that because that's
what we tell a lot of the guys on the
podcast so guys remember
two things be direct number one right
when you're gonna approach a girl if
you're interested just let her know
and then number two discovery trump's
disclosure every single time bro don't
brag about the [ __ ] that you have
let them find out organically that that
he was lying off ripped
and then two i started laughing when he
was oh yeah and then it's just and then
he asked someone for a number and then
he asked someone else for one and it's
like
it's just first of all i don't i don't
want you to have my number regardless
but it's like
how many girls in this group are you
gonna ask for
the number yeah that's a bad move going
for one girl and then going for her
friend because
the second girl will just feel like
she's a second choice
information and to top on that i think
it's even more disgusting when someone
asks you for your snapchat
however
okay this is an unpopular opinion i know
women won't agree with me
but i don't mind snapping like i think i
get
to know more about a person when you're
snapping because you can kind of like
make conversation based on where they
are
but i understand why people would think
it's
you know not classy
but i could see what they're saying
oh wait tripp people have asked me for a
snapchat
a snapchat what like i oh so we say
instagram right we always say on
instagram snapchat's for
for the birds bro yeah it's for the 12
year old yeah
yeah like there's a reason kids have
snapchats and here's the thing you're
you're how old are you 22.
22. yeah so guys you know they're 22 and
they're even telling you that snapchat
is for idiots
because you guys are younger you know
well thank you ask me
this is kind of glitching guys i think
this is going to be the end right now
your friends like embarrassing videos or
like just like
like i feel like it's more of a
the girls have like a group chat your
friends have a chat
[Music]
um let me know in the comments if you
agree or disagree don't forget to
subscribe